worried about the future of what might
be called polish Ukrainian relations and
studies in the historiography that will
we will see in the next 10 or 15 years I
am for two reasons one the field is
declining here in North America all pre
20th century history is declining I am
pleased to tell you that nine students
were roped into taking my early modern
graduate colloquium here at Columbia
dealing with both Poland and Ukraine so
that though that at least a bad level we
will exist but if you look around North
America at the moment the relatively few
people who have positions in the field
and why is that so important because
it's very important to have people
outside of those countries whatever
their origin is working on these topics
and I think they are frequently creative
and then on the other hand for the
reasons i will discuss as this talk
develops I think there are the 10 years
or 15 years we have now had a relatively
free exchange between Ukrainian and
polish scholars although producing some
very fruitful initiatives has not been
as productive as one might have hoped
and I'd like to lie outline why that's
been true first of all I'm going to deal
only with historian most people don't
really want to come to find out about
the sixteenth and seventeenth century
they want to know about its impact so I
will do this by telling you about
however the historiography has developed
and how their visions change changed of
late and i would start that by saying
that sometime between 1890 and around 19
25 to 29 in many ways Ukrainians in a
scholarly sense caught up with Paul's
they didn't equally volume of polar
scholarship and I don't say in all
levels they developed in all the fields
but Ukrainian historical research which
was much behind polish studies in 1890
was its equal for discussion by the
1920s and that great scholarly effort
met that there were two historiography
zuv to national movements two groups
later
on the state that were at sometimes in
discussion frequently I fee are not in
discussion as they ignored each other's
works or derided each other's works at
times but there are at least two
partners for some some discussion then
in the nineteen late 1920s and early and
through the 30s the Ukrainian tradition
is cut off and destroyed it is destroyed
fully in in Soviet Ukraine or almost
fully in Soviet Ukraine and it declines
very much in western Ukraine the great
scholar of this period professor kripya
cabbage never had a university position
in interwar Poland which is a sign of
where Ukrainians were in the discussion
with polish scholars so that the
Ukrainian tradition then is not anywhere
near equal to the Polish historical
developments by the late 1930s after
World War two the fates of course are
very different of those who are writing
on the polish-lithuanian Commonwealth
and on Ukrainian and polish history of
this period after a relatively short
time of enforced stalinism destruction
of some polar skull escala institutions
polish historical studies above all of
this period revived and revived rapidly
in the late 1950s in certain ways I
would argue enforced Marxism was in
certain ways even positive for this it
opened up new new topics to polish
historiography of this period and we
have someone from Poznan introducing us
but we didn't think of Topolsky and the
development of economic history and
Poznan as big Marxist influence but
above all polish historiography
developed because it was closely related
to the most creative centers of Western
historiography above all to the annales
cool to French historians they follow
the topics very closely of what's going
on they go into new topics and we have a
generation of giants in this field and
professor Mon shop recently recently
deceased who came and feed from Libya
werewolf is an example of someone who
was a historian of the polish-lithuanian
Commonwealth but was an internet
recognized scholar for the study of
topics of patrons and clients of many
social history topics and that could
happen in that polish historiography of
that period so it is a period that is
remarkably productive and I fear coming
to the end because fewer and fewer
students are going into history in
Poland of the caliber who went there in
that period and because people now can
work on the 20th century if they would
like in a way they couldn't have worked
on it in the 1960s and 70s and 80s